salieron de verdad y llegaron a parís
cinco días después
una carrera de 360 kilómetros para
recorrer la ruta del ataúd del soldado
desconocido el símbolo de la primera
guerra mundial que descansa bajo el arco
de triunfo
para mí es un gran honor llevar esta
llama que une a mis camaradas caídos con
el ejército de combate de hoy con el
presidente de manuel mccomb se unió a la
conmemoración
tras los habituales homenajes este año
las celebraciones fueron dedicadas amor
y scion nuevo a un soldado que se dedicó
a escribir el horror de las trincheras
durante la primera guerra mundial se
quiere es un fe
lo que hicieron escribir en off fue más
de lo que se le podía pedir a los
hombres y lo hicieron el 11
el cronista francés fallecido en 1980 se
unió a la cripta del panteón de parís
donde permanecen 70 hombres y 5 mujeres
que han marcado la historia de francia